hey everyone i'm abby sharp welcome to
abby's kitchen in response to a
ton of your requests today i'm turning
it back
all on you and reviewing your meals
now i asked you to send me a photo and
description of one or more of your meals
and snacks and i would give you my
honest thoughts
and i would try to review three
breakfasts three lunches
three dinners and three snacks to spread
the love
i have to tell you i received hundreds
of submissions within
hours and i did not purposefully choose
any of them i literally just opened an
email randomly and put it on my list
so if yours was not selected keep
watching for an upcoming episode because
if this video does well i will continue
to do them because i had so
much fun seeing all of your amazing
meals and snacks
i also want to note that the purpose of
this of course is to not analyze a
specific person's diet in the context
of their unique needs but to give all of
you
some ideas on how you can optimize your
meals and snacks
and also just some creative new ideas
for meal planning
and for snacks i know that i was really
inspired
now before we get into this a few
disclaimers
first of all the information in this
video is for entertainment and
educational purposes only
so you should always speak to a
healthcare provider about your unique
healthcare needs
second the recommendations for each
individual meal that i review is
designed to give you
a variety of ideas on how to optimize
meals for balance
variety and satiety whether or not one
individual meal or even one day is
balanced or healthy
does not matter in the grand scheme of
one's health especially if a person is
eating
in response to their physical and
emotional needs these suggestions are
just examples and inspiration for you
but you can also gather this data for
yourself over time by listening to your
body
three please be kind in the comments i
do not want to see
anyone shaming anyone else for their
food choices
and finally don't forget to subscribe to
this channel and ring that little bell
so that you never
miss out all right so let's get into
breakfast
starting with exhibit a
okay so my fan described this as two
eggs
two mini bell peppers a half cup of red
onions
and three cups of spinach cooked in some
avocado oil from a spray can
and topped it with some buffalo sauce
from noble made
she also had a honey crisp apple on the
side this
looks incredible i mean we have a solid
amount of protein
plus some fat from the eggs along with a
variety of colorful
antioxidant rich veggies a little hot
sauce for flavor without of course
adding
a lot of sugar and some carbs in the
apple
super balanced and i'm sure really say
shading
and if she wanted to beef this up a bit
maybe if this was like a post-workout
snack
and she needed a little bit more carb a
little bit more protein
she could throw in maybe some
nutritional yeast on top
and serve it with some whole grain bread
beautiful
let's move on to exhibit b
so this person said that after
experimenting with
a bunch of more typical breakfasts she
finally found something that kept her
satiated and full
so this is a breakfast salad with kale
romaine onions homemade sauerkraut
red cabbage broccoli carrots cucumber
half of a block of air fried tofu
a couple tablespoons of tahini drizzled
on top as well as a squeeze of
lemon she also said that this was the
best
breakfast for her after a night of
breastfeeding and that the rest of her
diet is
really high in carbs this is gorgeous
and i love that she's switching things
up from the typical
breakfast fair like oatmeal and toast to
find
something that works uniquely for her as
breastfeeding fuel
i can attest that the hunger when you're
breastfeeding
is intense so we've got lots of colorful
antioxidant rich veggies here
packed with satiating fiber we've got a
good amount of protein
from the tofu and some fat in the tahini
i also love that she's got some
sauerkraut on top and
we know that fermented foods have some
really important probiotic benefits
and i would say that depending on how
it's made a homemade version
likely has a lot more of those
beneficial bacteria
than a store-bought canned version which
are often made with vinegar
and have been pasteurized which can kill
off a lot of that bacteria
and while i would normally say we could
definitely add more carbs into the mix
if she said her snack and the rest of
her meals around this day are carb rich
and she isn't restricting then
ultimately that's all that matters
balance over the day or even during the
week is much more important to me than
achieving a
perfect balance at every meal but if not
i mean she could throw in some quinoa or
rice
or serve this with bread or fruit super
delicious looking start to the day let's
see exhibit c
i just love this shot it looks like you
know green juice to the rescue
and i don't know why that comes to mind
but like it's like a modern day
millennial popeye image for me right now
but anyways this smoothie apparently has
pea protein
kale banana avocado mango and flax seed
and apparently this fan has it with an
ounce of almonds on the
side to help boost the satiety factor
this is a pretty solid breakfast in my
books i mean we've got protein from the
pea protein powder and
flax healthy fats from the avocado
flax and the nuts carbs from the banana
and mango
plus we've got some extra fiber and veg
i also like that this person combines
their easy on the go smoothie
with a nice chewable snack like almonds
which
not only contributes some extra
satiating nutrition
but the sheer act of chewing may also
help with the psychological satisfaction
factor
i don't know i'm typically not a
smoothie person
because i feel more emotionally
satisfied
chewing my food sitting down but for a
fast
run out the door option this looks and
sounds awesome now let's move on to
lunch exhibit a
okay so this is apparently half of a
sweet potato
with some peppers and onions roasted in
oil garlic and salt
with some couscous and wilted spinach
first of all
i love how simple easy yet nutrient
dense this lunch is
we've got a lot of colorful antioxidant
and fiber rich veg
plus some fat in the cooking oil and
carbs from the sweet potato and couscous
and couscous is legit one of the easiest
fastest sides of life and to me
lunch has to be fast like no one has
time to cook an elaborate meal
in the middle of a busy work day so it's
either like really easy it's leftovers
or it's ubereats
for me at least so i would only suggest
boosting up the protein
maybe by adding in some canned beans or
canned lentils to the couscous to keep
it plant-based
and simple or even just kind of going to
town with what i sometimes call
sprinkles so nuts seeds nutritional
yeast
hemp hearts things like that but
otherwise i'm just
totally encouraged by how easy yet
satisfying this lunch looks
looks awesome so let's move on to
exhibit b
okay so this fan described this as her
favorite
low calorie quesadilla made with two
fiber one
wraps purdue fajita chicken strips kraft
low-fat mozzarella
100 calorie pack of guacamole and hot
sauce with lime and it's all cooked with
cooking spray
first of all love me a good quesadilla
it's
legit one of my favorite meals of all
time because
i basically just will use up whatever i
have in the fridge and then
chuck it in there with some cheese and
now i'm totally craving
quesadillas so thanks a lot for that
baby's kicking just thinking about it
so i get that this is supposed to be low
calorie as that was how it was described
in the email
but i don't think we need to necessarily
demonize full-fat cheese
if you compare crafts regular versus
their low-fat mozzarella for example
the regular has just one gram more of
saturated fat per serving
but the low fat has more sodium yet
they have the exact same amount of
calories and arguably
i don't know about you but i think
you're gonna get way more satisfaction
out of the real
full fat stuff and if you are watching
your sodium
just be mindful that there is quite a
bit of salt in things like pre-cooked
chicken strips and cheese and prepared
guacamole
though i am all for taking shortcuts
if they help you get a balanced meal on
the table in the middle of a busy day so
maybe just something to keep in mind
with your other choices later on in that
day
but i like that we have some higher
fiber carbs in the wrap
we've got protein in the chicken and
cheese and it's really convenient
and lots of healthy fats in the avocado
the only thing missing in my books would
be some veg so
i would personally try to pair this with
a salad
you know even chopped greens from a bag
would be really super easy
and really great let's take a look at
lunch c
love a good cold plate for lunch
especially on hot days when
i do not want to actually have something
boiling hot
so here we have a mediterranean white
bean and olive dip with some pita
we've got tomatoes and purple cabbage
slaw which has balsamic
cilantro and olive oil so delicious
looking
we've got some fat and protein from the
dip carbs in the pita of course
and fiber rich veg i personally probably
wouldn't be satisfied on this portion
and we'll probably want a bit more of i
don't know everything
but definitely the protein and maybe a
little bit more slaw because i just love
slot i love cabbage so maybe i would
just double up on the dip
or add like a little kabob of grilled
tofu fish or chicken
you could also do like a greek yogurt to
ziki if you want to keep it to the theme
like the no cook theme
but man like i love the color and i love
the creativity
that dip alone sounds totally divine
let's move on to dinner exhibit a
ah this looks insanely good
ah legit out of a cookbook so yeah
you've sold me
but this is a bolognese sauce made with
lentils and tomatoes
topped with vegan cheese nutritional
yeast and served with whole wheat pasta
love that we've got some plant-based
protein in there with the lentils and
the nutritional yeast
plus some fiber rich carbs from the
spaghetti and the lentils and some fat
in the cheese
all that i would probably add to this
maybe some veg so
whether that means kind of going half
season doing some zoodles
with the spaghetti or wilting in some
spinach or kale into the sauce
or just serving this with a little side
green salad with any of your favorite
greens or veggies but
looks like a really simple inexpensive
and
satisfying meal let's take a look at
dinner exhibit b
yum okay so here we have parmesan
coated baked chicken breast with a
spinach salad made with some red peppers
onion pine nuts and a homemade dressing
with olive oil apple cider vinegar
and dijon mustard and she's serving it
with a little dessert of rice cakes
topped with some almond butter banana
hemp hearts and dark chocolate
well the girl knew that i would approve
if she put some hemp hearts on top no
but seriously this looks great
um we've got a solid amount of protein
with the chicken of course
and some fat in there from the dressing
the nuts the nut butter
and the cheese and we've got lots of
colorful produce in the salad and the
banana
and a bit of carbs in the dessert sure i
do think that there's room for some
carbs in the main meal itself if you
wanted
i mean the dessert is even pretty low
carb for a dessert
so you could throw in some panko on that
chicken breast
or some berries grains or like homemade
croutons in the salad
or just serve it up with some sweet
potato or rice or some like crusty bread
i think that if you are having a higher
carb dessert
and feel best on the lower end of the
carb intake spectrum
it's totally reasonable to have a lower
carb dinner
but it's also totally reasonable to have
carbs with dinner
and dessert i mean you do what feels
good to you
and personally i do both depending on
how i'm feeling that day and
what else i've eaten that day ultimately
this meal looks really balanced and
doesn't feel restrictive at
all i mean we've even got chocolate so
i'm loving that
now let's round things off with dinner
exhibit c
okay this is an easy rice pilaf me with
cranberries almonds herbs and oil
stir with jarred ajvar which is like a
roasted
red pepper sauce and a whole roasted
cauliflower top with tahini
how creative i mean i'm getting so much
inspiration here too
so i love that we've got carbs from the
rice and the cranberries
we've got healthy fats from the tahini
almonds and oil
plus a good amount of fiber in the
cauliflower which is
standing in as like the star of the show
right now
all i would suggest is maybe bumping up
the protein a bit so
we could throw some lentils or chickpeas
into the pilaf just kind of
stir them in there or you could totally
hack that jarred roasted red pepper
sauce by
pureeing in some nutritional yeast or
some white beans
super delicious regardless and this
person has totally reminded me that i
need
to roast a whole cauliflower again
sometime soon
okay let's finish things off with my
favorite category
snacks starting with exhibit a
so for snack here we've got two sheets
of graham crackers
with a bowl of cherries and a string
cheese and
this fan says she's having a hard time
sneaking protein into her snacks
because she doesn't really like nuts or
seeds
i hear you girl i mean this is a common
question that i get from a lot of fans
who not only maybe don't like nuts or
seeds but may also have
allergies to them so first let's talk
about
what we've got going on we've got fat
and some protein in the cheese
and some carbs in the cherries and the
graham crackers and a lot of people
don't know this but just one square of
graham cracker has just one
gram of sugar so even though they do
taste pretty sweet
they're relatively low sugar and i
actually use them to make
toddler friendly pop-tarts which i'll
leave a recipe to
below so definitely check that out now i
don't know what brand of cheese string
that is
but one string cheese typically does
offer about six to seven grams of
protein which
isn't bad for a snack plus it has a
little bit of satiating fat
mozzarella cheese is typically the
lowest sodium cheese
and honestly even though these packaged
snacks
seem super processed fresh mozzarella is
just slightly lower in sodium so if
something like a string cheese is
convenient and easy for you
great i love all cheese but for other
even higher protein options
you could also dip the cherries and
crackers into some greek yogurt or cause
cheese
or make a chia pudding with yogurt and
milk and like
layer the cherries and crush some graham
crackers
on top or inside ah that would legit
taste like cheesecake
and i'm stealing that idea of mine for
myself
so let's take a look at snack b
so this is a bowl of greek yogurt bark
it's basically with greek yogurt
berries and lily's chocolate chips and
this fan has type 1 diabetes and lily's
chocolate chips
are sweet with stevia so they may be a
good choice for people who are watching
their blood sugars
and it looks amazing i mean we've got
protein from the yogurt
carbs and some fiber from the berries
plus little fat
and deliciousness from the chocolate i
mean it's such
a genius snack for summer and one that i
hope people will definitely get some
inspiration from because
i feel like the sky is just the limit on
what you could add here
so i would probably throw in some like
chopped nuts seeds
or hemp parts of course or swirl in some
nut butter for some extra healthy fats
i would also recommend using fuller fat
yogurt i don't know what she's used here
but
we do know and we do have research
linking the consumption of higher fat
dairy
especially fermented dairy like yogurt
to better weight management and better
blood sugar management
and if you have a mild sensitivity to
lactose
going full fat with your dairy may
actually help
because it is lower in lactose and early
research does suggest that one of the
fats in dairy butyric acid
may have some gut protective benefits
it's also just more inherently
saturating and arguably tastes
way better so do not be afraid to go
full fat finally let's take a look at
snack
c
so this is two chia rice cakes topped
with some almond butter and strawberries
looks delish i don't know what brand of
rice cakes this is
but i will say that even the ones that
i'm aware of that have chia in them
are still really low in fat fiber and
protein
i mean we're looking at less than a gram
each it's certainly not a bad option but
i kind of think of
all rice cakes as being pretty low in
nutrition on their own
and are more of like a vehicle for
getting nutrition
in so if the chia ones are way more
expensive than the regular ones
i would probably just go with the cheap
and cheerful bargain ones but i do
love that we have some fiber protein and
healthy fats in the nut butter
and some carbs in the strawberries and
rice cakes
but i would say if you did want the
benefits of chia i would probably just
sprinkle a little bit of the chia on top
or flax or hemp hearts or any other
nutrient-dense sprinkle
that you like but delicious combo and
totally something that i would do
myself so whoa we have a lot of amazing
ideas here and
i would be totally thrilled with any or
all of them
i mean can somebody please come over and
make me a meal
soon and if i didn't cover yours like i
said
i'm choosing randomly so check out the
description box for how to submit your
meals today
and of course a reminder to please be
kind and supportive in the comments
and if you like this video be sure to
give it the thumbs up
let me know that you like this if you
want more videos like this
leave me a comment below on your
thoughts on this new series concept did
you like it did you get something out of
it was it fun
i want to know also subscribe to the
channel and i will see you next time on
abby's kitchen
bye
you